Prince William may be the Duke of
Cambridge but he admits he struggled in
his role as a father like most dad
there's wonderful highs and there's
wonderful news
the 34 year old royal made a guest
appearance on top Vietnam Friday where
he got candid about raising
three-year-old Prince George and
one-year-old Princess Charlotte I
struggled at times the alteration from
being a single independent man to going
into marriage and then having children
is his life changing and I've I adore my
children very much and I've learned a
lot about myself and about a family just
from having my own children it's amazing
how much you pick up from just in those
moments
Prince William praises his wife Kate
Middleton for supporting him as he
navigates parenthood and he reveals how
both their children challenge him in
different ways but George is a writer
Roskill sometimes finishing with my toes
but he's a sweet boy and Charlotte is a
very mine I'm not a sister so having a
daughter is a very different dynamic so
I'm learning about you know having a
having a daughter having a girl on the
family
you